well there aren't that many cheaper
allies over time only the sixth since
1855 so we've served on average about 30
years each and that's a great luxury
because you start young and then you
have a lot of time a lot of people said
to me when I was chosen at the age of 42
on you're a little young for the job and
i replied no and believe me in this job
I'll age rapidly so and indeed I found
so every 30 years or so there is a year
or so of search for the next chief rabbi
there's a vote and I want
it was established because in Britain
throughout Europe actually the Jewish
community is constituted as a religious
community and that means that the
community must have I had an official
spokesman if you like who represents the
community visa V the public visa V the
other religious leaders the royal family
the government the Prime Minister it's a
kind of semi ambassadorial sep semi
diplomatic role and obviously there is
achieve route I've Britain for the same
reason lahav deal as it were not quite
the same thing as there is an archbishop
of canterbury and britain so there's a
head of the Christian Church though
there's a head of the Jewish community
which is constituted as I say as a
religious rather than as an ethnic
community
I wanted a turn I rather staid and quite
predictable Jewish community not very
creative one into a much more
effervescent community and I think the
community really has been transformed we
do things in Anglo jury today that are
not done anywhere else in the world or
if stimulated developments elsewhere in
the world we have something called in
wood we're almost three thousand young
people come together to study for a week
at the end of the year studying six
hundred different courses now loom wood
has been exported to 47 other places in
the world from Moscow to New York and
Los Angeles and almost everywhere else
so we have a very vibrant cultural life
which we didn't have before I wanted to
make Anglo jury a more religiously
knowledgeable community and in 1993 a
couple of years into my chief rabbinate
when i launched my program Jewish
continuity 25% of Anglo Jewish children
went to Jewish day schools today 17
years later that figure is sixty-five
percent and rising that means we've
built more Jewish day schools in the
last 15 years than in all the previous
350 years of Anglo Jewish history so I'm
pretty proud of that but in particular I
wanted to take the Jewish voice and make
it a voice in the human conversation so
I do a great deal of broadcasting for
the BBC and other national broadcast
media I do television programs a lot of
radio I right from the national press
seven of my books have been serialized
in the national press and when you
consider that the Jewish community in
Britain is any one half a percent of the
population of Britain it means that we
have an influence out of all proportion
to our numbers I'd like to see the
Jewish Voice much more self-confident
and willing to engage with the world
you